trois mois après la rencontre entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden en juin
dernier les discussions entre la russie
et les etats unis ont repris cette fois
ci à genève entre les numéro deux de la
diplomatie objectif de cette rencontre
tenterait de restaurer un dialogue
stratégique entre les deux puissances en
retrouve en direct de moscou notre
correspondant sur place antoine
claireaux à une fois antoine que retenir
de ces échanges entre ces dirigeants de
la diplomatie russe et américaine
oui stéphanie et bien sergueï riabkov et
wendy sherman ne s'en sont pas cachés
les deux pays ont toujours deux ou
d'importants différends sur ce thème de
la stabilité stratégique sur le contrôle
des armements mais malgré tout des
progrès ont été réalisés en effet les
deux diplomates se sont mis d'accord
concernant la formation de deux groupes
de travail sur ce sujet de la stabilité
de la stabilité stratégique écouter
aujourd'hui nous sommes convenus de
créer deux groupes de travail qui au
niveau des experts couvriront tout le
champ
le premier groupe de travail s'occupera
des principes et objectifs de la
maîtrise des armements à la peau
est le deuxième groupe de travail
traitera des questions de capacité d
action qui ont en effet stratégique
une fois nommé vous pouvez facilement le
voir ils couvrent tout le champ de notre
futur travail
et c'est une fois que les deux groupes
de travail seront à pied d'oeuvre qu'un
calendrier un nouveau cycle de
consultations entre moscou et washington
sera mis en place c'est rien de coiffe
également annoncé qu'à partir du 5
octobre une commission bilatérale
toujours entre moscou et washington sera
elle également formée elle elle aura
pour charge de négocier l'extension du
traité new start de réduction des
armements stratégiques alors pas de
grandes annonces pad annonce
exceptionnelle donc mais étant donné
l'état déplorable des relations entre
les etats-unis et la russie et bien
cette continuité dans le dialogue et
puis c'est ces quelques progrès mérite
déjà d'être salué et antoine il a donc
été question des relations russo
américaines
et pas seulement la question de
l'alliance militaire accuse dans l'inde
au pacifique acp a aussi été abordée
oui tout à fait cette rencontre a pu
permettre à la partie russe de
s'adresser directement la partie
américaine afin de demander des
éclaircissements concernant concernant
ce sujet de cette nouvelle alliance
entre les états unis l'australie et le
royaume uni et ses doutes concernent le
transfert possible de combustible
nucléaire concernant ses futurs sous
marins australiens la russie se
demandent en effet si les conséquences
de cette décision rentre dans le cadre
de la non-prolifération nucléaire et
s'inquiète des possibles risques de
détournement de ses activités nucléaires
d'un usage civil vers un usage du vers
un usage militaire
merci antoine perreault en direct depuis
moscou